[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
wenn ja bei solchen themen weiß ich
immer wie ich starte ich stehe jeden tag
auf und bin froh darüber dass ich gern
gesund bin und dass meine kinder
kerngesund sind aber ich bin auch von
mensch ich lächele gerne über probleme
hinweg das heißt werden emotionales
thema kommt dann lächle ich gerne dann
würde ich nicht leiden muss ich weiß
nicht ob es euch auch so geht aber das
heißt nicht dass wir nicht auch probleme
haben wir haben zum beispiel in der
familie
ich hab ne tendierten down syndrom das
ist gar kein problem denn meine tante
die ist der fröhlichste mensch den ich
einfach keine so lebensfroh so lustig
emotional wäre aber auch in der familie
das ist moritz lichte zum beispiel sie
ist schwerstbehindert und gestern
verstorben weil sie einfach seit 28
jahren ein pflegefall war also wirklich
ganz ganz schlimm da hab ich grad eine
story gemacht hab grad ost brot gebacken
in meiner küche unter morath läuft ryan
und die sorry die läuft noch und im rat
wenn sie dich im video und etwaig seht
ihr mich alle einig ja man sieht dich
und dann habe ich auf ausgedrückt und
sagte du die hasen wenn dies gerade
verstorben
und dann habe ich mir gedacht oh mein
gott ich habe erst mal vor den hall
krampf gekriegt weil ich meine
einerseits war es eine erlösung für sie
aber andererseits war es einfach so ok
ich will das eigentlich gar keinem
erzählen ich mache einfach weiter und
dann hab ich das toastbrot in der story
einfach weiter gebacken ohne mich zu
zeigen weil ich einfach so verheilt war
und ich habe mir gedacht kraft und das
sind einfach so dinge mit denen hast du
jeden tag zu tun und es gibt menschen
die haben das halt innerhalb ihrer
familie und ihr wisst ich habe ja vor
zwei jahren ein buch geschrieben
sally and friends und dieses buch da
geht der gesamte erlös an den
bundesverband kinderhospiz und dafür
habe ich auch damals den botschafter
engel bekommen weil ich einfach den
bundesverband kinderhospiz immer
unterstützt nicht nur ich sondern auch
er weil er mir fleißig bei der
buchproduktion geholfen habt ihr mir die
rezepte zugeschickt werden
dieses buch gemeinsam gestaltet
und haben somit ermöglicht dass das
sorgentelefon oscar finanziert wird und
in diesem jahr möchte ich wieder eine
aktion machen und zwar hat der
bundesverband kinderhospiz einen club
das heißt die grüne bande und die grüne
bande das ist ein club für
schwerstkranke kinder und jugendliche ab
14 jahren aber auch für
geschwisterkinder oder für kinder deren
eltern schwerst krank sind und die
tauschen sich dort aus die haben eine
eigene homepage die können über ihre
probleme und ihre fälle sprechen sie
können sie öffentlich machen und einfach
die welt auf sich aufmerksam machen
seit einigen jahren feiert der
bundesverband kinderhospiz den welt
hospiz tag im europapark in rust und
dieses jahr ist der schwerpunkt das
thema jugend das heißt dieses jahr wird
der song vorgestellt den die grüne bande
gemeinsam mit zwei musikern geschrieben
hat sie werden dort die welt premiere
feiern
und ich habe mir gedacht komm ich
unterstützt die aktion ich backe motiv
torte und wie ihr vielleicht an meinem
verhalten gerade steht ist es für mich
wirklich ein sehr schwieriges thema weil
ich einfach ein sehr emotionaler mensch
bin und ich meine auch der tod gehört
zum leben dazu
aber wenn es dann einfach kinder sind
finde ich es einfach so ungerecht und
vor allem geschwisterkinder müssen echt
ganz ganz arg darunter leiden weil
natürlich die eltern sich erstmal das
kranke kind kümmern müssen
deswegen finde ich ist es die aufgabe
von uns allen die grüne bande den
bundesverband kinderhospiz zu
unterstützen und ich mache mich jetzt
dran und planen jetzt die motiv torte
und nehmen euch damit in den europapark
und dann werden wir dort gemeinsam torte
übergeben okay okay jetzt überlegen wir
uns erstmal die torte denn das wird
glaube ich eine ziemlich schwierige
arbeit ja nun äußerst schwieriges motiv
das hier ist das logo die grüne bande
und in dem song den sie jetzt gerade
geschrieben haben ist eine zeile und das
grüne band hält uns zusammen also glaube
ich mache ich etwas mit einem grünen
band
ich habe ganz klassisch an mit einer
runden torte ich glaube dass ein
graffiti also mache ich das auf einem
backstein torte
[Musik]
und dann kann man ja dass bands wie
dieses solidaritäts band draußen
herumliegen
aber das ist nicht so langweilig ist so
etwas besseres einfallen
jeder hat sein kleines und großes
päckchen zu tragen und das grüne band
hält alle zusammen
und dann mache ich auf eine grüne bande
vielleicht finde ich noch ein paar
schöne zitate und die kann ich dann hier
noch drauf schreiben ja dazu bedeckt ich
mir noch im geschmack entweder mache ich
alle gleich oder jeder stein hat einen
anderen geschmack da gucke ich jetzt mal
eventuell macht vanille und schoko weil
das jedem schmeckt dann geht's los
wir backen jetzt erstmal kuchenteig ich
habe mich jetzt für einen schokohasen
gasteig entschieden das heißt ich mache
ein bisschen locker drei ein bisschen
schokolade das wird ein schöner dunkler
teig und ich glaube der schmeckt auch
jedem das ganze pack ich dann auf einem
großen blech und ich mache erst mal die
menge und wenn ich merke das wird mir zu
wenig mag ich einfach noch ein zweites
place und dafür verwende ich dann 260
gramm weiche butter 200 gramm zucker und
eine prise salz fünf eier die sind
zimmer waren 130 gramm nougat ein
päckchen backpulver 30 gramm cacau hier
habe ich etwas mehl das sind 240 gramm
260 gramm haselnüsse und 160 gramm milch
das nehme ich die weiche butter
am besten ist es immer wenn die zutaten
alle zimmer warm sind
aber wenn man spontan backt hat man auf
die zutaten nicht immer warm mutter
könnte immer ganz einfach zimmer waren
bekommen entweder kurz in der mikrowelle
aber nicht schmelzen sondern wirklich
nur kurz auf zimmertemperatur bringen
oder ihr reibt sie mit der küchen
reibereien und dann wird sie ganz
schnell war dann kommt hier das salz
dazu mit dem zucker und die zutaten
werden jetzt für vier bis fünf minuten
cremig verrührt ich kann die
zwischenzeit nutzen und die haselnüsse
fein mahlen die mal ich immer gerne
selber weil sie so aromatischer sind und
die milch noch erwärmen so etwa laura
wenn die butter masse dann soweit ist
kommt die eier dazu immer ein ei dazu
geben und dann halbe minute rühren und
dann erst das nächste ei dazu und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich auch noch den
nougat schmerzen
wenn ich hier die trockenen zutaten
vermischen also mehl backpulver und
cacau wir sagen einfach kaka und ich
lasse es jetzt dabei
die zutaten die werden jetzt gesiebt
damit das kakaopulver und das pulver
nicht lumpen und natürlich auch das mehl
erst mal noch die hälfte kurz einrühren
dann den nougat mit dazu und wenn jetzt
das mädel dazu kommt einfach nicht mehr
lange röhren da wirklich nur ganz kurz
immer bilden bis sich alles verbunden
hat damit der teig nicht speckig wird
sondern schön locker bleibt eigentlich
nur die größte fehlerquelle bei rührteig
nicht so gut
das war übrigens ein stück von der
nubert stange von der großen nougat
stange die ich von den mädels bei fieber
bekommen habe die handgemachten obert
stange und die benutze ich jetzt
natürlich zum backen und zum esch
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich einfach noch die
restlichen zu haben dazu die haselnüsse
könnt ihr gerne auch noch vorher rösten
ich lass das jetzt weg denn der luca
hatte schon einen richtig schönen
geschmack das in die hafen und ist schon
gerüstet
aber wenn ihr gerne einen noch
intensiveren haseloffs geschmack haben
wollt dann einfach noch die haare
zurecht und noch langsam die lauwarme
milch dazugießen und wie gesagt nur kurz
würden
ich nehme jetzt zum backen einen bug
rahmen dann habe ich gleich eine große
fläche dich dann schön etwas zu
schneiden kann und den stelle ich jetzt
hier auf 25 x 30 cm 1
[Musik]
25-35 ist doch besser natürlich jetzt
den teig verteilen schön und dann kommt
doch schon direkt in den backofen
und ab in den backofen und ich sehe
jetzt schon ich werde diesen tag noch
mal machen denn dort gibt es glaube ich
ganz viele hungrige gäste
[Musik]
den zweiten tag mache ich etwas anders
da nehme ich jetzt mandeln stadt
haselnüsse ich nehme vanille extrakt
dazu las den nougat weg und nehmen dafür
schokoladen streusel dann habe ich
nämlich so eine art stracciatella teig
die zubereitung ist genau gleich von
daher lege ich direkt los und zeigt euch
ein paar schritte
[Musik]
hier nämlich jetzt auch wieder den bug
haben
und da ist jetzt echt ganz praktisch
denn ihr könnt hier außen jetzt auch
ablesen wie groß das programm ist denn
ich habe hier eine skalierung
draufgemacht das gab es nämlich vorher
nicht auf eckigen back rahmen
und jetzt zieht er den einfach
auseinander und da wo eben die ecke ist
so groß ist richtig cool
[Musik]
beide kuchen teige sind gebacken und
abgekühlt ich habe es jetzt noch in den
kühlschrank gestellt damit ich sie
gleich besser zu schneiden kann
jetzt kommt die große frage wie fülle
ich die torten und da bin ich echt immer
so im zwiespalt denn einerseits will ich
immer neue kreationen und für euch
machen
andererseits wollte haben wir einfache
techniken und einfache krems denn so
eine motiv torte die brauche auch immer
seine zeit und die füllung ist hat nur
ein kleiner bestandteil die deko ist ja
immer so das meiste ich mach das jetzt
so ich mache eine französische
buttercreme da gibt es das grundrezept
auf einem kanal und ich mache jetzt
einmal die grundmasse das heißt eier
zucker salz die fröhlichkeit da kommt
die butter rein und dann halte ich das
ganze und macht die eine masse mit
nougat und die andere masse mache ich
dann mit heidelbeeren und limette und
damit ich noch ein bisschen crunch in
der torte habe in der dunklen torte
werde ich hier konflikts haselnüsse und
schokolade gemeinsam verbinden und dann
kann ich hier dass die französische
buttercreme vorbereiten dafür gebe ich
jetzt die eier in eine rührschüssel und
das sollte eine größere schüssel sein
denn es ist ja die große menge für beide
protokolle etwas zucker und da war ich
immer bis hin mit den zutaten und auch
mit dem zucker hier nämlich jetzt
weniger zucker weil ich einfach den
nougat noch mit dabei habe etwas salz
und die masse muss jetzt über einem
kochenden wasserbad erwärmt werden für
mindestens zehn minuten so erreicht die
masse nämlich 70 grad und alle keime in
den eiern sterben ab entweder macht ihr
das jetzt ganz klassisch auf dem
kochtopf also mit wasser unten drunter
oder einfach in der küchenmaschine so
mache ich das jetzt stellt die maschine
auf 70 grad ein und sobald die 70 grad
erreicht sind zehn minuten dann rühren
also die ganze zeit schon hören wäre dem
erwärmen aber dann ab dem zeitpunkt eben
zehn minuten stoppen und wirklich lieber
der minute länger als zu kurz
[Musik]
ja wir noch ein bisschen schokolade
zugefügt damit einfach nicht so wenig
wird und wir nicht ein wasserbad macht
dann nämlich wirklich total gern
stabilizer drunter denn wenn ihr den
nicht habt dann ist es so hört er na das
ist ja mal mögliches köpfen und vor
allem macht ihr so die töpfe und eure
behälter nicht gerade glas auf metall
ist immer ganz schlecht und so gut doch
nicht das ganze schön fest und ich kann
es später auch die arbeitsplatte setzen
und ist verrutscht nicht weil es einfach
aus silikon ist schokolade schmilzt hier
noch ein bisschen wobei die sich schon
fertig die nehme ich jetzt hier herunter
kann sich hier ganz kurz abkühlen lassen
ich habe jetzt noch ein paar große
stückchen drin die lasse ich jetzt aber
denn durch die restwärme schnell sind
hier auf jeden fall auf ich habe jetzt
auch nicht temperiert das ist okay aber
es kommt gleich auf richtige temperatur
dann gebe ich jetzt die heidelbeeren
rein
die gefrorenen nehme ich immer gerne
gefrorene ein bisschen einfach die
blaubeeren die außen und innen blau sind
und die kulturheidelbeeren die man im
supermarkt aus der frischetheke kennt
das handy trainer nicht mehr blau sind
das hat man deswegen gemacht aber
naschen einfach keine blauen finger und
keine blaue zunge bekommt und keine
blauen mund aber die haben einfach nur
richtig schöne farbe da gebe ich für den
geschmack man etwas elementen abrieb
dazu darauf achten dass man die schale
mit verzehren kann
und gleich noch den limettensaft denn
dann wird das ganze nicht blau sondern
so ein bisschen pink lila das veränderte
ein bisschen die farbe und jetzt gleich
ein bisschen zerdrücken und solange
einkochen lassen bis die flüssigkeit
fast leid uns drückt
[Musik]
man kann ich jetzt hier die hasel
besonders zur schokolade geben
die richten so gut sind geröstete
gehackte haselnüsse und die cornflakes
[Musik]
da achte ich jetzt einfach nur darauf
dass die kontext wirklich komplett mit
der schokolade ummantelt sind
denn ohne schokolade ausnahmen würden
sie natürlich werden sowie in milch und
so bleiben sie hoffentlich gleich große
torte jetzt hier auf eine folie geben
oder auch ein backpapier
so mache ich jetzt schon mal einiges
vorbereitet die heidelbeeren kochen ein
den nougat werde ich noch schmelzen und
die weiche butter
die werde ich jetzt auch mit dem
schneebesen richtig schön cremig
verrühren
in der zwischenzeit sind zehn minuten
auch schon vorbei das heißt ich nehme
jetzt die hitze herunter von der masse
also einfach vom kochtopf wegnehmen und
kalt rühren das dauert dann auch
ungefähr 20 minuten schneller geht es
wenn ihre frische schüssel namens die
kalt ist da kurz umfüllen und kalt
rühren
[Musik]
die butter masse ist cremig die eier
zucker massa ist abgekühlt
das kann ich jetzt also schön beides
verrühren
[Musik]
die französische buttercreme wird nun
halbiert die eine hälfte für rühre ich
mit dem heidelberg und die andere hälfte
mit dem weichen nougat so schön die
butter 10 jetzt etwas weich denn in der
küche ist es wirklich relativ warm
die ständig ganz kurz in den kühlschrank
und kann schon mal den kuchen rausholen
und zerschneiden jetzt wird zuerst
einmal die dunkle torte zubereitet kurz
raus lösen
ich hab sie schon hier auf den torten
retter gezogen und jetzt werde ich hätte
sehr verschiedenen rechtecke zu
schneiden
das mache ich jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen intuitiv ich bin uns einfach
die tankkarte so ein bisschen als maß
[Musik]
und dann mache ich später noch aus dem
hellen kuchen hier vorne was flacheres
wo ich dann eben auch das logo drauf
machen kann und vielleicht hier noch was
kleines oder sogar was oben drauf
da gucke ich einfach noch an zitiert die
creme drauf gestrichen die nogat creme
[Musik]
ist echt noch ein bisschen weich aber im
kühlschrank wird die gleich fest ich
erhalte ich jetzt die karte dagegen so
kann ich nämlich streichen oder das was
runter läuft
[Musik]
jetzt seien krank
dann nochmal buttercreme obendrauf damit
es jetzt schön flach wird weder man hört
sie knusprig es ist das zweite stück
obendrauf perfekt und genau so fühle ich
jetzt noch die kleine torte hier und
stellt dann aber in den kühlschrank
damit die torten schön fest werden und
nicht verrutschen wenn ich sie gar nicht
glatt streichen will
[Musik]
die helle torte wird jetzt mit etwas
marmelade und mit der heidelberg
buttercreme gefüllt
[Musik]
ich habe ihn für euch vor gekostet er
ist sehr lecker und nicht so süß sehr
gut
jetzt kommt alles in den kühlschrank
oder in den gefrierschrank damit es
richtig schön fest wird und dann könnt
ihr entweder das ganze mit der
buttercreme fertigte streichen oder ihr
macht noch eine garage statt zu der
kanalstraße ist eine creme aus
schokolade und sahne
ich mache es jetzt mit der garage garage
einfach insgesamt immer schneller
festwirt und dann habe ich später etwas
einfacher die torten und zu streiten
das heißt ich mache es eine dunkle oder
helle kanada findet ihre rezepte als
grundrezept bereits auf einem kanal und
sobald die garage abgekühlt ist und die
torten hier kalt sind geht es gleich
weiter
jetzt sind die trocknung gekühlt und ich
nehme hier den drehteller mache da auch
immer gerne den stabilizer drauf dann
rutscht nämlich nichts und kann jetzt
ihr die erste torte schon mal nehmen
hier streiche ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen buttercreme rein weil an
einigen stellen ist einfach noch ein
bisschen fehlt und versuche jetzt
einfach die torte so gut wie möglich zu
gestalten und ich stellte zwischendurch
dann immer wieder kühl und wird dann zum
schluss die garage nehmen zum richtigen
glattstreichen buttercreme geht auch
aber die folgen schon erwähnt wird die
garage einfach schneller fest und bleibt
dann eben auch schön hart unter dem
konto
[Musik]
die künste der trotte überprüfe ich
jetzt einfach und stellt schon mal die
deko her
ich habe hier das logo grüne bande finde
ich echt schön graffiti logo und das
mache ich jetzt heute schon mal dann
habe ich schon mal den größten teil
nämlich hinter mir und habe das einfach
schon mal safe und ich nehme jetzt dafür
was sondern ich weiß noch mit einer
neuen ich hab ich auch gebraucht es im
verband und hole dann diesen sieben kilo
aber ich habe mir einfach auch alle
meine rest ist und das heißt ihr könnt
die immer luftdicht verpacken in seiner
heimat geben luftdicht verschließen und
dann sind die wirklich schön haltbar und
ich hab jetzt irrt das merke ich schon
eine masse blüten passte und fondant
habe ich noch ein bisschen was übrig das
nämlich jetzt auch wieder schön
verschließen und hat das silikon matte
da steht übrigens auch der umgang mit
von land blüten passte und modelle
schokolade
das heißt da steht zum beispiel darauf
habe ich darauf geschrieben fette deine
hände mit kokosöl und knetet die
modelliermasse weich und dann habt ihr
da so ein paar angaben die rechte immer
ganz gut gebrauchen könnte und dann auf
etwas becker stärker aus holz schön dünn
ausrollen und es geht eben besser wenn
ihr von dann mit blüten passte vermischt
[Musik]
das ist dünn genug passt auch perfekt
den überstand den schneide ich jetzt mal
gleich weg
[Musik]
das kann ich jetzt wieder zusammen
kneten und wieder luftdicht verpacken
und hier lasse ich jetzt diese von damit
decke kurz antrocknen dann kann ich
nämlich besser drauf malen und jetzt
über tragt ihr dieses motiv auf den
angetrockneten von dom und jetzt
probieren wir mal was aus man nehme ein
geschenk das ist ja aus acrylglas und
lebensmittelecht dann lege ich da die
schablone drauf die von der decke drüber
ihr kennt das wahrscheinlich noch so ab
1000 am fenster man sieht es schön durch
aber wenn ihr jetzt hier noch im licht
unterlegt geht es besser
ich nehme jetzt zum erhöhen meinen
tortenring der reflektiertes licht und
jetzt nehmt ihr eure handy taschenlampe
oder eine etwas bessere taschenlampe
legt sie hier drunter und das hier drauf
ich sehe es schon ganz gut ich nehme
jetzt allerdings unser equipment die
leuchte legt die hier unten rein aber
mit der taschenlampe vom handy klappt's
auch oder nimmt eben eine andere
taschenlampe oder zum beispiel
schreibtischlampe nicht rein q cells
jetzt drauflegen erweckt es glaubt und
so könnt ihr jedes beliebige motiv
einfach abpausen mit kratz und
schriftzug ich meine was frei hand malen
das geht bei mir noch relativ gut das
kann ja auch gut aber sondern schriftzug
den möchte ich schon originalgetreu
machen und jetzt nehme ich hier einfach
diese lebensmittel farbstifte und
zeichne sie einfach ich pause ab diesmal
ist ab pausen erlaubt
die bäcker stärke könnt ihr übrigens
ganz einfach hier oben auf der
oberfläche weg bruder
das ist nämlich eine reine
kartoffelstärke das geht mit puderzucker
und speisestärke nicht so gut
jetzt hatte ich eine schöne glatte
oberfläche und kann malen
[Musik]
das grundgerüst steht ihr könnt jetzt im
prinzip mit den stiften einfach
weitermachen
ich finde aber etwas cooler wenn man
jetzt noch mit pulver arbeitet das heißt
ich habe ziele lebensmittel farbpulver
und teilweise werde ich selbst verdienen
also etwas verflüssigen
da könnt ihr entweder kokosöl nehmen
oder zum beispiel etwas alkohol
verdunstet nämlich ganz schnell mit dem
pinsel verrühren
am besten auf einer stelle außen erst
mal ausprobieren
gut das ist kein schönes lena ich
brauche ein anderes thema gut dass ich
es ausprobiert hat wir machen es jetzt
ganz klassisch rot mit blau und hoffe
dass ich dann ein schönes lila bekommt
[Musik]
wenn ich hier ein bisschen gelbes
farbpulver und das kommt jetzt hier
außen dran und damit kann man diesen
rauchigen effekt machen
[Musik]
und dann kommt das lila an die reihe und
damit mache ich hier' diese farbspuren
[Musik]
was geht's erstmal trocknen morgen früh
werde ich hier noch ein bisschen mit
pulver dran arbeiten für heute ist
glaube ich genug was ich gemacht habe
die torten werde ich gleich noch ein
bisschen fertig einstreichen und morgen
werde ich dann die gesamte optik fertig
machen und die trotten fertig ohren also
feier abzuhalten
gestern habe ich antworten nicht mehr
weiter gemacht es war einfach viel zu
spät heute bestreite ich sie jetzt noch
komplett glatt das heißt ja bezieht die
garage wenn die mal zu fest wird können
sie sehen der mikrowelle oder über dem
warmen wasser raten noch einmal erwärmen
damit sie ein bisschen weicher wird also
jetzt einfach schön drauf geben und
schön rechtwinklig gert streidt
[Musik]
fertig ich habe auch noch die deko zu
machen also ich putze kurz wohlmeinend
von dort und dann stellt man die deko
her
ich habe jetzt hier fondant rot und
schwarz gemischt starte ich jetzt noch
ein bisschen was übrig von der
hochzeitstorte das benutze ich jetzt
hier einfach weiter schön weich kneten
und dann auf beckers strecke ausrollen
und ich habe jetzt hier am auswahl starb
meine 5 mm räder dran
das heißt egal wie sehr ich jetzt hier
noch aus roller ist bleibt immer auf
einer 5 mm stärke größe von land gleich
gleich dick gleichmäßig und ich spare
mir einfach die treffer
[Musik]
ok 15 meter dick ich tausche kurzem 83
mm raus
[Musik]
die bäcker steigt dann einfach ein
bisschen ab insel
ich werde jetzt hier den mathe einfach
schon mal strukturieren dass das
backstein muster reinmachen
dafür nehme ich mir ein model werkzeug
ein stumpfes und ein lineal wenn ihr
keinen genial habt könnt ihr auch
einfach debatte benutzen denn ich habe
hier dieser ein zentimeter skalierung
das heißt er legt euch hier einfach zum
beispiel entlang und stadien und können
es dann auch benutzen und jetzt zeichne
ich hier einfach die streifen ein und
dann die querbalken für die bergsteiger
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier schon mal das muster
hier die torte die torten bespricht
immer gerne mit back prince bringt damit
davon dann eben auch gut haftet ihr
könnt aber auch noch mal kurz in der
dünne schicht gar streichen
und normalerweise überzieht die torten
immer in einem ich mache jetzt aber so
ich schneide die seitenteile zu und
stand die decke oben und setzte es am
einzelnen zusammen so kriege ich jetzt
ein bisschen genauer hin
also einfach hier die höhe und die
breite abmessen einzel zu schneiden und
dann dran setzen
[Musik]
jetzt sind alle torten überzogen ich
muss echt sagen die tochter ist recht
aufwändig auch wenn sie gar nicht so
aufwendig aussieht denn alle trocken
glattstreichen einzeln überziehen die
musterungen reinmachen nimmt sehr viel
zeit in anspruch
und jetzt habe ich hier einfach einen
torten retter und machen sie mal die
anordnung der torte denn ich habe keinen
jackpot was groß genug ist das heißt ich
werde jetzt gleich eine platte zu
schneiden aus holz gucke jetzt einfach
wie ich die maße mache ich würde ja so
ein bisschen kompakt machen damit das
grüne band gleich die torten alle
zusammenhalten kann
[Musik]
ich glaube dass ein gesetzlich doch
vielleicht hier oben drauf meist nicht
aber ich denke vom grundmaß der platte
passt es hierzu ja jetzt zu schneien
40 49 40 mal 40
die oberseite der torte bekommt auch
noch einen schönen abschluss dafür
benutze ich die torte als schablone und
schneidet dann den deckel zu
das grüne bande logo wird dann noch
ausgeschnitten und direkt auf die
oberfläche der kleinen torte geklebt
dafür nämlich etwas s-bahn kleber
[Musik]
im randbereich sitzen doch bisher mit
lebensmitteln pulver und bestreichen die
holzplatte mit lebensmittelfarben
[Musik]
jetzt können die torten drauf gesetzt
werden
[Musik]
ich habe für alle trocken wird echt so
viel ich nehme jetzt noch eine kleine 1
oder 2 2 die mache ich jetzt auch noch
fertig und da gucke ich probiere das
jetzt einfach wie ich halte hier dieses
eine gebäude hat uns jedoch gleich im
schnitt dort worte das war eine
schokotorte mit schock denn man sieht
und hört den crash und man wird ihn auch
schmecken sagt sie jetzt da dran
[Musik]
jetzt können auch das grüne band das uns
alle zusammenhält ich habe jetzt hier
bereits ein band aus honda ausgerollt
und ausgeschnitten
ich habe ich jetzt noch einträge rat
fuchs ich habe ich jetzt noch einträge
rad und damit präge ich jetzt hier noch
den rand ein so bekommt etwas struktur
einfach nur noch den abschluss machen
dadurch dass ich hätte die torte etwas
umgeplant habe ich natürlich noch was
übrig was bedeutet das für uns kein
problem also 16
das hat eine torte gebacken für die
grüne bande das ist ein club für
jugendliche ab 14
die entweder selber schwer krank sie um
deren eltern speckstein oder
geschwisterkinder und ja die halten da
alle zusammen und damit gerade nen song
rausgebracht der benötigt europa park am
sonntag wird der praktisch dass die
weltpremiere
und ich habe mir echt lange überlegt was
ich machen sollte und ich wusste nicht
und zur erklärung also die haben das
logo selber entwickeln so als graffiti
und dann fiel mir gleich backsteinmauer
ein so eine wand zur graffiti auf die
war mit und dann habe ich mir gedacht
mach' ich so viele kleine und große
päckchen weil jeder sein eigenes
päckchen zu tragen hat und es gibt keine
probleme und große probleme und manchmal
sind es probleme und noch mal probleme
oben drauf und ich dachte das grüne band
das hält dann alle zusammen was mir
jetzt im nachhinein ein feld ich hätte
auch diese anderen päckchen eigentlich
bund machen sollen
meinst du regenbogenfarben weil jedes
problem wirst du doch jede geschrieben
jedes schicksal ist irgendwie so anders
farben und ja aber das ist die
geschichte zur torte
da muss nicht mit der linken ein
lebensmittel fahren sie so echt wie
viele dinge ich freue mich echt schon
auf dem zaun ich bin echt gespannt auf
und ja das haben jetzt noch übrig ja ich
dachte ja mal gespannt was drin ist also
so kannst du gar nicht erkannt weil es
vor dass buttercreme da ich dachte aber
jetzt rennen in unserem genau der ist
hell und bestenfalls sorge es gibt zwei
das ist der herr lang darum schön jetzt
ob er auch mal das hier ist das
stracciatella heidelbeeren und das ist
schokolade schmeckt ich bitte gott was
da kommt ist natürlich schocker kostis
habe ich gemacht ja genug harte nuss
[Musik]
während als würde ich sagen ja und hab
ich probiere gerne kein problem damit
das kann die torte im kühlschrank
einfach noch durchziehen und dann fahre
ich in den europapark zur veranstaltung
wenn sie wissen gar nicht dass ich
kommune tor doch was wäre eine
überraschung
also jetzt geht es zum europarat korrekt
geführt
ich mag es so freien kuchen und ein
bisschen die führung reicht völlig aus
und was ist das eigentlich
[Musik]
nein die ist die grüne bande gehen sie
mal suchen
jetzt sind wir im europa park in rust
angekommen die torte habt richtig gut
überstanden die euromaus heute schon
probieren aber ich sagte nein nein er
ist für die grüne bande und da gehen wir
jetzt direkt man hinkommt
[Musik]
interessiert tag im europapark gleich
gehts los
es werden ungefähr 400 gäste kommen ich
bin extrem gespannt darauf wenig
kennenlernen werde
[Musik]
unsere zeit ist begrenzt seine wie meine
beine wieder ein spiel
in der schweiz präsent
wir sind nicht normal aber völlig normal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das abnehmen die ein bisschen schwer
sich gerne ich habe eine torte gebacken
weil ich dem klub der grünen band
wirklich super finde ich selbst bin
botschafterin des bundesverbandes
kinderhospiz schon seit über zwei jahren
ich habe damals mit meiner community
einfach ein bug punkt gemacht und koch
und backbuch ist bei youtube kanal und
erreicht wirklich jeden monat millionen
von menschen und bei mir auf dem kanal
da gibt es keine diskussionen über
politik über religion über gut oder
schlecht es gibt einfach nur koch und
backrezepte ich mache tutorials wie man
kinderzimmer einrichtet und bei mir ich
sehe mich immer so ein bisschen als
botschafter zwischen allen bilden meine
eltern kommen aus der türkei ich bin
aber in deutschland geboren aufgewachsen
da wird nicht über religion gesprochen
über nationalitäten weil es wirklich
alles irgendwie 1 und alles schön und
man darf oft das ist immer ganz schlimm
man wenn man selbst nicht betroffen ist
dann sieht man es oft einfach nicht
das heißt wenn man selbst kein krankes
kind hat oder niemand in der familie hat
dann nimmt man das vielleicht gar nicht
so wahr und moment muss mich krank und
ich sehe mich dann immer als vermittler
zwischen welten ich zeigt auf seinem
youtube kanal dass es die grüne wandel
gibt ich zeigt den bundesverband
kinderhospiz und ich hoffe dass durch
dieses video was ich über die torte
gemacht habe und über euch gemacht habt
einfach ganz viele menschen auf euch
aufmerksam werden und ihr einfach ganz
ganz viele unterstützer findet
[Applaus]
vielleicht sollte ich habe mich echt
schwer getan weil das einfach auch so
für mich ein emotionales thema ist ich
habe lange überlegt was mache ich denn
überhaupt alternative logo hat mir super
gefallen das coole graffiti logo und
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht mach' ich
das logo einfach auf so eine
backsteinmauer damit ist das wirklich
schön rauskommt und ich habe mich eine
torte gemacht sondern viele torten und
habe sie dann mit dem grünen band
verbunden weil jede torte sozusagen ein
päckchen ist manchem ein großes päckchen
manch ein kleines päckchen zu tragen und
diese torte die verbindet alle
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt ist die veranstaltung zu ende und
neben erst den abdruck ist ja eigentlich
der grund warum es überhaupt die kühne
grüne band gibt
wie kannst du überhaupt überhaupt auf
die idee also das herz einfach genervt
dass wir hunderte new vision immer
wieder ausgegrenzt wurden und auch die
öffentlichkeit daran gemacht wurden und
generell blick haben oft ist sie also
uns gefällt haben immer von uns
gesprochen und dann brauchst du meine
zeit verlieren
der arzt spricht bedeutung aber nicht
erst wenn das hat mich irgendwann
ziemlich genervt so dass es dann
zusammen die kraft genommen und geschaut
habe hey warum machen wir nicht ein klub
von uns zu berichten
der einfachste und selbst reden können
und unsere probleme mal im kasten des
kaufs trennen und zahlen können müssen
auch noch da wird dann heißt es nicht
dass ich keine alles machen kann oder so
und ja ich bin froh die freunde schon
sehr aktiv sehr groß geworden aber ich
bleibe ich natürlich man braucht mehr
weit
dazu kommen und dann auch reaktionen
fragen können und ja ich bin glücklich
sein club muss dass die kunden besser
ankommt in vorarlberg die jetzt einfach
eine eigene stimme ist auch richtig
schön lang für die aktion
also ich glaube ich auf jeden fall
unterstützen ich hoffe dass mit diesem
video ganz viele menschen auf euch
aufmerksam würden auf die trainerbank
und ganz viele menschen dazu sage ich
danke für dein sollte und auch sina hat
wirklich ganz toll ausgedrückt was sie
mit der grünen bande sagen wollte und
auch ihr könnt helfen ich bin ja
botschafterin des bundesverbandes
kinderhospiz und in deutschland gibt es
allein über 40.000 familien mit kindern
den nielsen werden also schwerstkranke
kinder deren leben einfach verkürzt ist
wenn er sagt mensch ich möchte es auch
helfen
ich will auch gutes tun dann könnt ihr
einfach eine sms schickt an die 81190
mit dem text stern 0 1 und dann wird
einfach ein euro von eurem guthaben
direkt an die grüne bande überwiesen
oder ihr macht sogar stern 05 dann gehen
direkt fünf euro an die grüne bande
ziemlich einfach kann jeder von zuhause
aus machen und vor allem könnt ihr viel
sport machen
ich bin richtig glücklich die torte kam
super an
die veranstaltung war richtig schön hier
ist es sowieso immer schön ich habe
jetzt hier mein grünes armband gehört
auch zur grünen bande und ich hoffe dass
wir gemeinsam noch eine richtig tolle
aktion machen können dieses oder
nächstes jahr und nächstes jahr bin ich
gerne wieder mit dabei ist hierbei der
veranstaltung und ich hoffe dass wir
alle mithelfen könnte ein bisschen mit
macht und den song könnt ihr euch alle
auf der homepage der grünen wand
anschauen also bis zum nächsten mal